la grande mosquée de tours vient de
franchir une étape symbolique la pose de
son dôme central il vient coiffer
l'édifice en travaux depuis 2010 son
coût 270000 euros financée par les dons
mais il faudra encore patienter pour
voir la mosquée de 3000 places
totalement terminée hélène chapelet
c'est une nouvelle étape qui vient
d'être franchie sur le chantier de la
future mosquée de tours la coupole qui
donne sa particularité au bâtiment
religieux est en train d'être réalisés
depuis le mois de novembre de trois à
cinq coureurs se relaient sur place pour
réaliser la charpente qui servira
ensuite de support à une toiture en zinc
donc là on volige c'est une double peau
mais de deux épaisseurs croisée de
volige donc c'est du bois traité c'est
pour ça qu'il est jaune et ensuite ce
sera recouverte de zinc c'est la
première mosquée après il nous est
arrivé de déjà travaillé sur des
châteaux sur des coupoles un peu comme
ça oui c'est une certaine fierté parce
que bon bah c'est pas des
des chantiers qu'on fait régulièrement
quoi
deux cent trente deux mille euros vont
être nécessaires pour finaliser cette
coupole de l'argent qui provient des
dons des fidèles depuis la pose de la
première pierre en 2008 la mosquée a
déjà bien avancé mais elle est loin
d'être finie
les princes arabes nous donne pas
d'argent
les fantasmes c'est la communauté qui
qui financent et ce qui fait beaucoup de
sacrifices ça mérite quand même que
quand le ce bâtiment que cette mosquée
se termine les musulmans sortent au
soleil faut il faut pas qu'on reste dans
le local
parmi les travaux qu'il faut encore
financer la couverture du hall d'entrée
et des deux bâtiments d'ablution le
chantier débuté en 2010 est donc loin de
connaître son épilogue